so peter is over an hour
laughing like they're joking
about that yeah
there's only one answer
no no seriously i don't like that
you're disrespecting robert perez
again one of the best players ever to
play in the premier league
[Music]
we meet again yeah
how are you feeling about this
interesting debate but you know how it
goes if you two can't agree
i get the decisive word so my word here
is completely final so you're the guy
all right exactly i want to start up
here we're going 4-4-2 because you won
the champions league playing 4-4-2 and
you played 4-4-2 that whole season so
we're going to do it in a 4-4-2 so no
issues there but these two center
forwards the debate will be is it
thierry marie and dennis burkhamp or
wayne rooney and carlos tevez and justin
this is hard to separate isn't it i'm
finding it very difficult um is it it is
isn't it is it difficult here we go
we're off robbie tell me tierra henry's
definitely in there best striker ever to
play in the premier league i don't
necessarily agree on that
and dennis burkham is in there because
you know i find it hard to even separate
them too as two of the best players ever
to play in the premier league i'm going
to say this like wade munet he was in
his prime he was fresh
we just bought him 2005 he was coming on
and we won the league the previous
season and he just blossomed and he was
in his prime he was peaking and i'm
going to go for wayne rooney because the
guy he scored goals carlos tevez
workhorse he'll work he'll do something
for you but he's it's the connection he
was better at yeah
it's the way you left it's the way it's
the way you left i'm sorry we're waiting
are you falling around your sword when
it comes to color seven if you're not
putting you're looking at it my points
are very okay
so if you have to have one of these in
if you have to pick one of your two i'm
going to do like a poker move now yeah
[Laughter]
you know that it's so stupid but you
know what i think you know what i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to use my
powers my omnipotent powers here i think
that we have to agree that tyrion re is
that one and the debate is rooney or
burkamp
burkham
you know and you've got to think about
combinations
yeah
think about combinations as well i don't
know tyrionary and rooney i'm not sure
that rooney complimented everyone that
everyone he played with vanessa roy it
didn't matter who rooney picked it
to your crazy
but who says there's gotta be only one
manchester united's top ever goal scorer
england's top ever goal scorer
is that right to leave up
yeah
and we'll sort something what's that
gonna do with me man united stock goal
scorer you know i'm talking about burke
burke camp he's got a statue
at the emirates stadium so is thierry
henry
get him got a statue for rooney
that's combination because you are a
combination as well don't you you want a
combination and that was the perfect
combination for me maybe the combination
is what's going to be the decisive
factor well played because i was
actually leaning towards rooney because
i can't believe that we're going to
leave wayne rooney out of any like
whatever team you see what wayne rooney
can do i know 16 years old arsenal's on
being record wham
buddhism pack 89th minute
talk the ball busted it straight past
saving left hand top card no no there's
no doubt that wayne rooney is where you
go
we're talking about the invincible
season imagine now you're a defender
coming up against them too now
the only the only thing is
i feel like wayne rooney and thierry
henry would almost be
perfection like no i'm not perfection
ori and burkham are already perfection
why change it and our front pairing
is certified
it is thierry and dennis burkham robbie
would you like to do the honours i have
two arsenal counters for you
so you guys if you want
put those two on the subs you know me
there you go teary
dennis slightly behind
at least he's not felt tips
we're not drawing positions in that
right so up next i want to go to another
fairly controversial debatable position
i'm gonna go for this position here the
left wing it's between robert perez who
was a glorious footballer or
cristiano ronaldo so perez or ronaldo
again one of the best players ever to
play in the premier league
oh you just seen you you did see
cristiano ronaldo ballon d'or winner
three times premier league title winner
five-time champions league winner
european championship winner oh man
wasn't that there he wasn't that yeah at
that time he was just a little
young with a snapper coming through
bumpy faced and i mean them times perez
was killing it in that invincible team
perez was unreal
unreal um
seriously ronaldo was unreal in that
season as well you're talking about 40
real madrid right now 40 league goals up
to 44
nearly 24 25 league goals 16 goals in
all renewable competitions nearly 14
champions league goals as well
but they're all done in oh 708 and he
took off we're on about vacation
we're on about the season of the that
champions league win yeah well he
contributed that season pires was
unbelievable in that team he was a
wonderful cristiano wonderful player
oh 708. do you know what andy i've got
to intervene you know you said he scored
in the final which he did yeah and he
missed the pal hey
he was a winner in the end yeah he was
all right he was young
if it was a debate between robert pires
and anyone else almost anyone i think
the answer is pirates but it's cristiano
ronaldo and therefore i'm leaning
towards thank you agreeing with andy
we're giving one congratulations this
counter is yours thank you
it was never in doubt anyway no you know
what i just don't stop this never in
doubt thing for me it's just
it's just
john and a lot of that is influenced by
what he went on to do center half
partnerships rio and vidic sol campbell
colo torre
it was one of a kind lack of bruce
palista it it was it was so strong and
they could give it out and take it as
well third nano vidic
two great players um i do think it's
going to come down you know i'm being
theory i would say
one of each
and to me
colo torre was a revelation that season
but it's got to be soul campbell's got
to be in there it wasn't just
his defensive abilities right
it was also that his leadership
he was a leader in that team
right so that's what to me gives him an
edge
that gets him in there as well and he
had all the toughness
and athleticism and he was just an
unbelievable defender plus we got him
from tottenham which made it even
imagine
imagine the mental toughness of this guy
to leave
tottenham their captain
and then to come and play for us what is
that christmas for you when that was
transferred it was it was just christmas
it was christmas it was
it's
double duty
got everything it was brilliant
right trust me so listen i love the guy
for what he did but to me i think he has
to be in there everything robbie said
there's totally right about sol campbell
so campbell does have to be in he was
immense soul campbell is in but then i
also think that there is an obvious
second candidate here like rio ferdinand
is arguably the best defender that the
league's ever seen but who was better
rio or village if you had to say i know
it's difficult because they played
together but if it's one or the other
who you leaning towards i would go
vinnich because he was really yeah no
but he was all toughness it's the
toughness in it rio was like
on the game he knew he knew he knew he
knew how to
manage a defense he knew when they're
balling or when it was coming in but
when you needed toughness even goals in
the last minute he would i've seen him
scored a couple of goals for us when we
needed it i think that the partnerships
they both deserve a representative but
no partnership was good enough to have
both so i'm going to say that you can
both have a counter and it's your
decision that's for you rob it's for you
andy for me it's quite straightforward
it's so campbell
[Music]
i'm gonna go with real
i'm gonna go with real but
an honorable mention for the amanda
vidic because he was a tough sob i'm
telling you at left-back we have two
candidates really it's ashley cole or
patrice evra but if you don't mind andy
just because i find it really
entertaining
we're going to start with robbie and
we're going to ask robbie to talk about
his left back
this will
listen we discovered this kid it's a bit
like sakura now
came through
discovered him and he was a revelation
and to me at that time
and even when he went on to chelsea to
be fair to him it's best left back
in the league yeah i completely agree i
don't even think it's fair to compare
ashley cole to patrick server if you're
talking about actually calling
comparisons you basically need to talk
about only
paolo maldini maybe roberto carlos like
he is the best
of all time and he's in that debate for
me and i do love him so he's here and
i've got yeah
seven million quid from monaco and
they've just been to the champions
league final
pound shop around the corner yeah
yeah or you can go to louis vuitton yes
yeah guaranteed seven million questions
i can guarantee you my louis vuitton
will turn more heads he's in ashley cole
robbie we're doing it
[Music]
in january they have thrown straight
into a manchester derby and it was awful
but from there they went on to with
carling cup premier league title
european cup three league titles league
cup fa cup they won the he won the lot
in four and a half years but he doesn't
really have a great career patrice evra
isn't even the best manchester united
premier league here at left back he's
we're talking about ashley cole he's the
best ever this is
[Applause]
so over to the right back and now it's
now it's a bit trickier because neville
slash where's brown
you what are you going to go for i'm
going to go there neville a limited
player limited player gary neville
worked so hard from the night class of
92 all the way through like i said 18
years of dedication
yeah not given that and he won
everything dude we've got to judge it on
we've got john
he played consistently
what did he do that you know oh he was
through the entire season
let's hear your case for lauren the most
underrated right back probably of all
time really he was so underrated he was
absolutely solid trust me he was tough
if he was out of the team i'm like oh no
lauren's not playing
i rated that guy so highly he's never
really had his flowers what about his
contribution to that season would it
have been the same contribution it's
brilliant again the team with the whole
season without losing at that integral
to that he was integral to that he was
integral to that defense look at what we
did that season a whole season without
losing a game yeah and to do that your
defense has to be
unreal i agree because our defense was
unreal
what did you go and beaten oh for the
whole season so we won the european cup
and that defense was
for the season and a premier league
title in the same season the fact that
you had two that year the fact that it
was brown or neville makes me think that
it just has to go lauren
i think it does robbie congratulations
that's another one in there looking very
heavily arsenal at the moment you're
going to have to up your game a bit
because he's now south divide this
this one so you need to level up me i
feel like there may be trouble ahead but
we're going to go for the central
midfield now i'm going to put skulls and
uh carrick okay and rob gilberto vieira
what are you saying
gilberto vieira okay
are you are you assuming that it's that
the partnership is gilberto oh yeah i'm
assuming
i'm assuming
i'm assuming that that's done already oh
this is the north south divide again
of course it is no no north south divide
maybe you need to just face up to the
facts right that that team
was better the invincible team was
better than that united team and i'm
sure even you ed would admit because you
guys still sing songs about him at man
united right the vieira is definitely in
there is one of the best
midfielders of all time
in the premier league oh yeah yeah even
as well with michael carrick they were
instrumental in that in that season paul
scholes could pick a pass
so michael carrick look up see
where the runners are point them out and
play play it play a ball in
just like
if you don't have a good midfield you
don't get you don't get the gold supply
in front is there anyone that has to be
in it for you if there's a hill that
you're going to die on here who is that
one player that has to be in it pulse
goals
he's an absolute and you've suggested
that patrick vieira
warehouse okay so just in the spirit of
dayton's is there a world in which
you
say skulls and you accept that and you
say vieira and you accept that which
means no gilberto silva and no michael
carrick yeah i can go along with that a
midfield of
the era and scores
it's a pretty good midfield yeah
that was in the spirit of dayton it was
very grown up there i think that's
probably fair i think that's probably
the correct way of doing it which then
leads us on to
right winger this is a tricky one for
you isn't it andy
yeah yeah because you had two crackers
that season you out there nani
and you had g sun park
absolute
workhorse
it would it will go through brick walls
for you rob obviously this is
in that season
is jason park a better player than
freddie lumber no
but
[Laughter]
put it down
jason park technically no
but commitment effort
work
work great
desire pushing forward and when he got
dropped he never moaned he always come
off the bench and did a job you're
comparing json park who don't get me
wrong
he was a very good player
but i'm sorry he does not compare to
freddie youngberg in his pomp how good
was freddie lumber
tell me what
it sounds like some people are missing
the
but i brilliant people acknowledge
the ultimate boxer box midfielder work
rate but with skill
scored goals
and i think you said it earlier big game
player when you in your big moments when
you want someone to
to turn up it was in andy i've got some
bad news for you oh this is crud this
this is absolute garbage
you need to make you what are you what
are you doing wrong here you've got a
team that won three leagues in a row in
a european cup and you're getting you
ain't doing nothing wrong it's just that
that team
invincible team is a one-off
yeah enough when this is done you're
going to be sneaking behind me back as
harley
we've got any brown envelopes are going
to
you can still have some pride we're
going to go goalkeepers jen's layman
or vancouver ben foster
andy i'm willing you on here
you can do this
who is it vandasar you're talking
ayak's school
of excellence progression dutch national
team snip
you got cheap oh cheap
right layman again integral
to that season
season unbeaten a revelation in that
season loved him as well all the housery
that he did that year and
i love layman the only thing with him
sometimes just loses his head a bit
in big moments
you know he used to lose his head i
always
the champions league final still hurts
me
it costs you he did he crossed him yeah
because it's good because to me i i just
thought he could have done better
remember what we did
set the record for the most clean sheets
in a season i i don't know if it's a
premiership record but it's a manchester
united record
it the amount of minutes we didn't
concede a goal it was like something
like 12 up to 14 games overall van der
sar was a better keeper he's a quality
keeper i used to rate him i actually
remember when you signed him i remember
thinking that would have been a shout
out for us
but
if we're looking at that season
to your season
it's two records in itself damn i'm
saying season's me andy
congratulations you've done well here
you pulled it out the bag with the stat
the fact that he had that that i want to
check that's that as well and you know
what he did save the penalty to win the
european cup when he saved from nicholas
and elka hit straight up want to slip
want to slip my congratulations
i'm surprised that this is quite the
landslide 7-4 to robbie i'm going
conspiracy fairly yeah it's the north
south divide yeah not soft divide me
slightly
this is jfk this
this is envelope brown envelopes little
little surprises
it's fantastic do you know what you know
what i'm really looking forward to
seeing the comments of this video
because people will be letting us know
where we've got it you know what i've
got one last thing i think the manager
should be wenger as well
cheers
[Music]
this is chelsea against an all stars of
the world
and golocante makes it as a player i
think fabinho is actually probably just
edge as kante as a dm brother stop
smiling at me you couldn't even say that
with a straight face
on the ball he's better than kante